things are living and things are growing
on the roof so they're always living and
growing and the flowers look amazing oh
man and you know the flowers are
bringing the pollinators yes we got the
butterflies coming we got the birds
coming so it's going down which is
magical because when you're downstairs
you're in skid row and you know it's a
very intentional space that has been
ignored on purpose and so being able to
grow food in this space I mean that's
everything I think you named it surface
level what we get to experience is all
of the organized abandonment yeah but on
the rooftop we're able to elevate in so
many other ways and not just simply
coming up the stairs but you know
walking on a rooftop and just breathing
fresh air much like many other
low-income communities access to fresh
fruits and vegetables is slim to none
right you know it's important to have
this space it's important to be able to
have these Gardens to grow and to be
able to just relax there are so many
ways to bring nature and plants into
urban industrial areas but one issue
that troubles every rooftop farmer is
access to water I I remember when I was
here and I was watering things by hand
using city water
and one time I left the hose oh
yeah
that was the bill that I was
like a high water bill but but I have
these friends they have a similar setup
now they're really focused on trying to
figure out how to bring water to their
Garden in a way that isn't going to
drive their water bill through the roof
I want to check in with Pete about some
exciting technology from a company
called skywell that has totally changed
Pete's water game as long as there's 27
relative humidity in the air this large
machine creates 100 gallons of water per
night right and so when you're not when
you're in a region like Los Angeles
that's you know adjacent to the ocean
there's always going to be at least 27
relative humidity in the air and so we
built a reservoir and we just started
using water from the clouds to actually
feed our Gardens
an atmospheric water generator uses
technology to collect water from the air
fans pull air over a cooling coil which
prompts condensation the water droplets
are collected and filtered for drinking
or watering Gardens the collected water
can be stored in a reservoir and hooked
up to a drip irrigation system that's
set on a timer
so this means that you're not on public
city water so with the current setup
that we have we are using some we're
using 50 less wow oh water that's right
and that's significant yeah that is in a
place like Los Angeles that's amazing my
friends at bluma they are just pumping
their water from a lower level up to
their rooftop farm and I mean that's
running their electricity bill up and
it's just difficult it's hard on their
system you have to make it as easy and
as comfortable for folks to Garden
because if if ease and comfortability is
not there the garden will die right
Farmers know right and urban Farmers
know all too well that the cost of you
know of running a garden the highest
cost is the water yeah and then the
water that is being harvested is that
drinkable water oh yeah you can bathe in
it you can cook in it and it's delicious
it's locally sourced I mean how many say
that how local yeah yeah this is my
water right here yeah I'm about to drink
you later right so yeah that's so cool
and Skid Row I mean there's no water in
Skid Row there's no real facilities for
people to use there's no drinking water
so for us to be able to offer this as a
place for people to come at a
destination for people to come and get
fresh clean water is amazing I mean
that's a game changer for us that's
incredible sweet yeah I'd love to try
some downstairs
thank you
[Music]